I remember being 14 years old the first
time I ever stepped into a gym
it was a Glendale YMCA I was six 135
pounds not only was I the skinniest kid
in the gym I was a skinniest kid in our
high school no one in school was
skinnier than me nobody if you go back
to school right in it and you asked him
about Patrick David at 14 Delta he was a
skinniest kid in class chives to wear
for shirts t-shirts on top of each other
and a sweater just to look normal on how
skinny I was
and I remember first time I went to the
gym this guy named Freddie that he has
no idea of an impact he made in my life
I was so intimidated of going into the
gym Fred pulls me aside one day says
Patrick let me explain to what you need
to do with this workout thing he says I
want you to not look at anybody in the
gym for two years and don't compare
yourself to anybody it's not a fair
match right now he said start off with
increasing your benchpress every single
week by two and a half pounds all you
need to do is add an additional two and
a half months every single week to
whatever your bench presses so I start
off with a 45 pound barbell and next
week I had two and a half pounds then
five pounds and seven and a half pounds
and ten pounds and twelve and a half
pounds are you're late on bench pressing
the plate on each side which is about
135 times your Apted on bench pressing
up late in 25 which is 185 your apt a
time bench pressing two plates then two
plates in a quarter then three plates in
three plates and a quarter and then from
them curling 90 pound dumbbells all
these other things and then you know I
wanted to be a bodybuilder at that time
but that's simple little principle of
him telling me 25 pounds completely
changed my life I was 14 years old it
validated that no matter what you do you
cannot compare yourself to anybody for
two years because you're always going to
feel disappointed all you need to figure
yourself out is whatever business you're
doing what can you do to add that
additional 25 pounds to your gig what is
the 25 pounds in your business is the 25
more calls is it three more calls every
single day is it five more contacts you
make every single day what is it what is
that two and a half on principle to your
business because it ever since that part
where there was financial services where
there was social media whether it was
YouTube value it doesn't matter what it
is the principles always been very
simple for me always always
always always focused on beating your
prior best and then one day you'll wake
up being the best of the best in your
industry at least competing with the
rest as long as you focus on increasing
whatever it is that you're measuring
like 25 pounds every single week so
focus on beating your progress
eventually be won the best opportunity